grab the tissues uh because yeah giving
back such a beautiful way this holiday
season by fulfilling the wish of a
longtime fan diane berberin a runner
triathlete and iron man competitor who
has terminal bone cancer pink joined
diane on zoom for a 30-minute
conversation helping her check off one
of the major items left on her bucket
list take a look at their emotional
heart to heart
i have bone cancer that's spread now to
my liver and um
it's just out of control you know so now
i i've had all this activity and i have
to like go decompress physically and
emotionally so i'm gonna take a little
time out
good you know
but
i just
follow you all the time i'm not i don't
not your stalker or anything but i know
it's kind of odd like a 63 year old
woman's like chasing me around
but
but i like that you you weren't offended
by the fact that i said that no pink
needs to meet me oh i love it i'm like
good yeah i do i'm like she's totally
right you have a kind of bravery that i
don't understand you're bringing comfort
to other people while you're walking
yeah you're walking through this yeah i
always say i'm climbing this time with
stairway to heaven now i'm just walking
the path
just trying to get it all in but i lived
large before this
you know i did a lot i did a lot of
everything i wanted to do
um personally professionally uh
athletically
and
you know how else would i die
i'm gonna die the same way
working on it making it the best i can
you've made my day
thank you that's i mean i don't even
know what's on my bucket list now
because you were so far at the top and
all the other things started to happen
so it's kind of like
okay i think it's something else because
i am going to rest for a couple days but
something else is going to come up
this is just a beautiful act of kindness
that you did for me
i mean totally made me cry
peed my pants
right already i sat down i said doesn't
anybody want to put a piece of plastic
underneath us because i pee again
yeah
but i held it together
so
thank you so much you're amazing
beautiful family
and
i just love your energy